et has a roundup of the stars doing good  and making their fans dreams come true  we always got a little surprise coming  first up Dwayne the rock Johnson gets a  little choked up while responding to a  fan the actor received a phone call from  the make-a-wish Foundation and sent a  special message to the thirteen-year-old  boys just for ty to see you're in  Honolulu Hawaii you are you're a big fan  of mine I want you to know even though  I'm not able to see you and be with you  I want you to know you're already one of  the most amazing and coolest kids I have  ever spoken to you're stronger than I  will ever be ever made since Ron then  there's Beyonce making a sweet FaceTime  call to Houston teen ebony banks  battling a rare form of stage four  cancer after graduating high school  early her next goal was to meet queen  bee and her senior class made it happen  [Music]